tesla is one of the most recognizable
brand names currently in the electric
vehicle market and it deserves to be the
market leader for electric vehicles
tesla single-handedly created the market
for commercial electric vehicles by
making electric vehicles that were safer
reliable and packed with features when
tesla's first car the tesla roadster
came out it blew away every other car in
the same price range it was faster had
good range and best of all since it was
fully electric there were no emissions
and now elon musk might be moving into
disrupting the motorcycle market with a
fully electric tesla motorcycle
currently the motorcycle market is
dominated by internal combustion engine
motorcycles like harley yamaha and honda
but tesla might soon change that just
like tesla uprooted the internal
combustion car industry they have the
potential to uproot the motorcycle
industry let us take a look at the
concept motorcycle design that tesla is
rumored to be working on the concept
design the concept electric motorcycle
is called the model m and from the first
glance of this design it looks amazing
it has a sleek and aerodynamic look to
it and those are complemented by these
exotic curves the tesla model m is not
only supposed to be a motorcycle lover's
electric alternative but rather the
model m will surpass all conventional
motorcycles in terms of speed and
performance and that won't be that hard
for a fully electric motorcycle just
like fully electric cars fully electric
motorcycles have the advantage of
instantaneous torque a fully electric
tesla motorcycle will be driven by a
powerful motor that can provide instant
power this translates to really fast
acceleration times this is the same
reason tesla cars have such great 0 to
60 times because electric motors don't
have a power transmission lag that cars
running on internal combustion engines
do the model m concept design is a
premium motorcycle competing with the
likes of suzuki hayabusa or the kawasaki
ninja tesla always goes for performance
but with style and aesthetics and this
is what we see with the model m the most
striking feature of the model m is the
large top-down display mounted in the
front of the motorcycle this is a pretty
huge touch screen panel that curves
upward toward the driver and
aesthetically resembles the screen on
the tesla model s model m fits right
into the tesla ecosystem with a large
dashboard in elon musk's design
philosophy of tesla vehicles being
computers on wheels the concept design
goes into detail about the top display
touchscreen this display screen would
have a day and night mode for better
visibility in different lighting
conditions and will offer the same kind
of features we have come to expect from
tesla display panels things like
instrumentation control of the
motorcycle navigation control media
control battery level and other vehicle
data will be displayed on the display
panel this will allow the rider to have
seamless control over his motorcycle at
all times the design combines the
display panel with rear mounted cameras
to allow the rider to see what is behind
them easily this can help the motorcycle
rider to change lanes and turn without
having to physically turn back and look
around the rear view will be displayed
on two separate display panels that go
into the place where side rear view
mirrors are usually installed the rear
view cameras would have the ability to
dim based on lighting conditions and
will have anti-glare capabilities for
really sunny conditions it makes sense
that such an aerodynamic and streamlined
design aesthetic also has zero profile
foot pegs the foot pegs will rotate out
of their place once the key fob of the
model m is nearby when not in use the
foot pegs will retract back into place
and will erase any indication of their
existence by blending into the body
seamlessly the concept has the turn
signal lights on the back side of these
foot pegs this is an interesting place
to install the turn signal lights but
you have to agree they do look right
there the concept design also goes into
smart air suspension the motorcycle
would be able to lower the motorcycle's
height and reduce its frontal area in
the process and it's not limited to that
according to james the model m should
also have the ability to adjust the
stiffness and make the drive more
comfortable for the rider since this is
just a concept design we don't have any
specifications to talk about but if
tesla does something similar to the
model m those specs will blow away
everyone tesla motorcycle when can we
see it electric motorcycles are becoming
an increasingly popular market around
the world some estimates but the
electric motorcycle and scooter market
to be worth 30 billion dollars and with
increasing concerns about going green
the demand for electric motorcycles is
likely to go up tesla hasn't really
jumped into the market yet but that
hasn't stopped other companies from
jumping in harley-davidson the classic
motorcycle brand from the us has already
dipped their toes into the electric
motorcycle market livewire by harley
davidson is a fully electric motorcycle
that has a traditional cruiser build and
the specs on the bike are impressive it
comes with 105 horsepower and a 0 to 60
of 3.1 seconds but it is kind of pricey
other companies like zero from
california are also jumping into the
electric motorcycle space they have a
wide range of offerings starting at 9
300 tesla can still easily dominate this
market if it wanted to tesla has already
shown that it can scale production tesla
is already producing excellent electric
vehicles at really competitive prices
leveraging their existing design and
manufacturing capabilities to produce a
tesla electric bicycle would be
relatively easy for the company and
doing so could create a monumental shift
in the electric bicycle industry unlike
anything seen before there are various
concept designs on the internet for a
tesla motorcycle the renderings and
images currently floating around the
internet aren't by tesla officially but
instead they are by independent artists
the design we just looked at is by
artist james guley just to be clear this
isn't an official design but rather an
artist's rendition of what a tesla
motorcycle could look like but there
have never been detailed plans either
released by tesla or elon telling us
that they are working on an electric
motorcycle elon did hint that tesla
might do an electric motorcycle in the
future in 2018 elon musk said that tesla
might very well build an electric bike
one day as a response to someone on
twitter but since then there has been no
news on this elon musk has a very
complicated relationship with
motorcycles he once revealed that he had
a history with a motorcycle because of a
horrible accident in a tweet replying to
a question about tesla doing motorcycles
he said i actually used to ride
motorcycles when i was a kid i was into
dirt biking for like eight years or
something then i had a road bike until i
was 17 when i was almost killed by a
truck so we are not going to do
motorcycles a tesla branded motorcycle
would be an interesting vehicle to say
the least tesla has already proven
itself in the four wheel sectors maybe
it's time tesla starts thinking about
moving into the two wheel sectors